iyonik Bağları işlemişti Şimdi sıra
geldi kovalent Bağları işlemeye kovalent
bağ nedir Hangi tür atomlar arasında
oluşur nasıl meydana gelir bundan
bahsedeceğim küçük bir hikayeden
bahsedeceğim Ondan sonra polar kovalent
bağ apolar kovalent bağ Bunların ne
anlama geldiğinden bahsedeceğim o
şekilde dersi bitireceğiz dostum ama bak
bir şeyi fark etmedim de sanma
geliyorsun buraya konuyu öğreniyorsun
ama abone olmadan izliyorsun Bak bu beni
üzüyor abone ol daha güzel içerikler
ürete Hadi o zaman vakit kaybetmeden
başlayalım Bak burada büyük bir molekül
vermişim Ben bir sürü atom var karbon
var hidrojen var oksijen var Sonra ne
var burada azot var ondan sonra kükürt
var bir sürü atom bu neymiş asetil
sistein diye Bir maddeyi ne oluyor bak
buradaki karbon atomu şöyle hidrojene
bağlanmış şu karbon atomu diğer karbon
atomuna bağlanmış şu karbon oksijene
bağlanmış burada azota bağlanmış azot
hidrojene bağlı burada karbon kükürte
bağlı gibi işte Burada bir sürü atom var
peki Bunlar ne atomu yani karbon
hidrojen oksijen azot kükürt Bunlar
ametal atomları ve şöyle bak aşağı doğru
gittiğimizde bu moleküldeki karbon
hidrojen oksijen azot kükürt atomları
Neydi bu Bağları oluşturuyordu ve bunlar
ametal atomları ydı ametal atomlarının
şöyle bir özelliği vardır
elektronegatiflik değerleri birbirine
yakındır iyonlaşma Enerjileri değeri
yaklaşık olarak birbirine yakındır bazı
atomlarda bunu söyleyebiliriz ve ametal
atomlarında iyonlaşma enerjisi yüksek
olduğundan elektron vermeye çok da
yatkın değildirler yani elektron
vermeleri kolay değildir elektron
vermeyi çok istemiyorlar iki tane ametal
atomunu düşün bağ oluşturmak isteyecek
Hani iyonik bağda ne vardı birisi
elektron veriyordu diğeri de o elektronu
alıyordu E şimdi bunların ikisi de
elektronu vermek istemiyor diyor ki sen
versene bana Yok ya sen bana ver diyor E
ben vermek istemiyorum diyor öteki diyor
ki ben de vermek istemiyorum ama bağ
yapmamız lazım o zaman gel ortak
kullanalım diyorlar işte bunun
detayından bahsedeceğim burada Bak
görüyor musun iyonlaşma enerjisi
değerleri bu şekilde büyüktür Şuraya bir
not yazdım bu önemli Bak yukarıda da
vardı buraya Ayrıca yazdım ametal
atomlarının iyonlaşma enerjisi büyük
olduğu için elektron alışverişi yerine
elektron ortaklaşması yaparlar Bunu
aklında tut Dostum şimdi metal atomları
hep elektron vermeye yatkındır O yüzden
metal atomları ne yapar hep iyonik bağlı
bileşikler yapar bileşik oluşturduğunda
iyonik bağlı bileşik yapacaktır Çünkü
elektron verecek diğer ametal atomu da o
elektronu alacak burada iyonik bileşik
oluşacak ama ametal atomları aynı
değildir metaller gibi böyle elektron
vermeye yatkın değildirler genellikle
almaya yatkındırlar e iki tane ametal
atomunu Düşünsene Tamam bir metal
elektronu verdi ametali aldı İyonik bağ
oluştu ama bir ametal var bir başka
ametal var ne yapacak İkisi de vermek
istemiyor o zaman burada iyonik bağdan
bahsedemeyiz dostum elektronu vermeyecek
ortak kullanımdan bahsedeceğiz şimdi
aşağıda da var ben onu bir örnekle de
anlatacağım zaten hem Aynı tür ametal
atomları hem de farklı tür ametal
atomları arasında oluşan bağ kovalent
bağ olarak ifade ediliyor mesela burada
şöyle bir şey vardır hidrojenle
hidrojeni düşün hidrojenle hidrojen
arasında bağ oluşmasını istiyorsak ne
oluyor biliyor musun Şimdi bir hidrojen
burada bir hidrojen burada bağ
oluşturacaklar diyelim elektronları
birazdan söyleyeceğim ortak
kullanacaklar Peki bunu neden böyle
yapıyorlar Çünkü ikisi de elektronu
vermek istemiyor elektron vermekte
zorlanıyorlar Bundan dolayı ortak
kullanma ihtiyacı hissediyorlar burada
ikisinin de elektronegatifliği aynı
olduğu için o ortak kullandıkları
elektronları eşit güçte çekecekler
mesela H2O molekülünden bahsedeyim şöyle
H2O diyelim sığdı değil mi ekrana Evet
burada bak hidrojenle oksijen arasında
da ne yapılıyor elektron ortaklaşması
oluşuyor Çünkü ikisi de ametal ama
burada hidrojenin elektron negatifliği
oksijenin kinden küçük olduğu için
elektronlar ki elektronegatiflik ne
demekti bağ elektronlarına sahip çıkma
gücü O zaman bu ne demektir hidrojeni
daha azdır oksijeni daha fazladır işte
bağ elektronlarını oksijen daha fazla
tutmak isteyecek ve böyle bir kovalent
bağ oluşacak bunu da birazdan polar ve
apolar olarak ifade edeceğim işte
elektronların ortaklaşa kullanılmasıyla
oluşan kimyasal bağ ya da güçlü
etkileşime Biz ne diyoruz kovalent bağ
diyoruz ve şöyle bir şeydir E şey olması
için yani ortak kullanılması için olay
şudur bir atom bir elektronunu verecek
Öteki de bir elektronunu verecek verecek
demiyorum Tabii ki getirecek ortaya
ortak kullanacaklar ya işte iki elektron
bir bağ oluşturmakta dostum Bak unutma
onu hemen şuraya not olarak yazalım her
bir atomdan birer elektron gelmesi ile
bir bağ oluşur şimdi bak sana kovalent
bağı bir hikayeyle anlatmak istiyorum
Bir Varmış Bir Yokmuş şöyle yaklaşım
sana bir varmış bir yokmuş bir köy
varmış Bu köyde iki tane şey varmış
Çiftçi varmış böyle Köylü birisi Yunus
emmi Olsun birisi de Mesut emmi olsun
bunların ikişer tane öküzü varmış Bunlar
işte tarlalarını sürmek için çifte koşma
diye bir şey vardır öküzlerini böyle
işte sabana takarlar böyle tarlalarını
sürerler iki tane öküz gerekiyor Onun
için tarlalarını bu şekilde sürüyorlar
mış günün birinde Mesut emmi gitmiş şeye
ahıra Bir bakmış öküzünün biri ölmüş
ağlıyor sızlıyor Tabii Eyvah gitti
Öküzüm gitti Öküzüm Ondan sonra aklına
geliyor diyor ki ben bir Yunus emmiye
gideyim diyor Onun nasıl olsa iki tane
öküzü var diyor şöyle Ersin de diyor Ben
bir tarlamı süreyim diyor gidiyor bir
bakıyor ki Yunus emmi de oturmuş ağlıyor
diyor Ne oldu diyor ya benim Öküzüm biri
öldü diyor Hayda diyor senin de kaldı
bir öküzün Benim de kaldı bir Öküzüm
diyor e tarlaları sürmemiz lazım diyor
Ne yapalım Ne yapalım Yunus Emmi diyor
ki gel diyor bu öküzleri ortak
kullanalım bağlayalım aynı şeye Ondan
sonra tarlaları sürelim diyor Aa çok
güzel fikir diyor harika çok güzel hemen
bağlıyorlar Mesut Emmi diyor ki hadi
benim tarlayı sürelim önce diyor Yunus
Emmi diyor Olur mu öyle şey önce benim
tarlayı süreceğiz diyor benimdi senin de
tutuşuyorlar ya benim işte Öküz a
Benimki de var burada falan filan
Muhtara çıkıyorlar muhtar da diyor ki
bunlara Semih hemm olsun o da Muhtar da
diyor ki önce benim tarlayı sürelim
sonra sizin işi hallederiz diyor böyle
saçma bir hikayeden bahsedeyim Neden
bunu söyledim Çünkü kovalent bağ öküz
ortaklaşması dır Bak burada Mesut
emmiden bahsettik Yunus emmiden
bahsettik iki tane hidrojen atomu var
birer tane elektronu var şimdi şöyle bir
şey vardır bak helyum diye bir atom
vardır değil mi helyum soy gazdır soygaz
şimdi hidrojen en kolay kime
benzeyebilir helyuma benzeyebilir değil
mi Bir elektronu alsa diyor ki oh mis
gibi diyor ben helyuma benzeyeceğim
Çünkü diğer atomlar soygaza benzeyerek
kararlı olmaya çalışır işte bak Mesut
Emmi'nin bir tane elektronu var şöyle
duruyor bir tane elektronu var ee Yunus
Emmi'nin de bir tane elektronu var yani
öküzü var işte bak birlikte kullandılar
ve tarlalarını
sürebildiği
ve işte Ne oldu hidrojenle hidrojen
arasında bir bağ meydana gelmiş oldu
yani ne yaptılar Bak bu elektronlar önce
kendi çevresinde dolanıyordu yani atomun
çevresinde dolanıyordu ve şöyle bir şey
vardır Şu anda potansiyel Enerjileri
sıfır her bir atomun potansiyel enerjisi
ıır sonra bunlar birbirlerine yaklaşmaya
başladığında ne oluyor biliyor musun Bak
bunun elektronunu bu Proton çekmeye
başlıyor bunun elektronu bu Proton
çekmeye başlıyor E bu elektron kendi
çekirdeği tarafından çekiliyor aynı
şekilde kendi çekirdeği tarafından
çekiliyor toplam çekme Kuvvetleri daha
fazla şu anda değil mi he potansiyel
enerji böyle Düşme başlıyor bir miktar
düşüyor burada itme kuvveti ise sadece
çekirdekler arasındaki bir itme kuvveti
var ha elektronlar arasındaki az ama
sonuç olarak burada çekme Kuvvetleri
daha fazla sonra birbirlerine
yaklaşıyorlar yaklaşıyorlar Öyle Bir an
geliyor ki itme ve çekme Kuvvetleri
dengeleniyor İşte o sırada bu Molekülün
potansiyel enerjisi minimum düzeye
düşüyor çok daha düşük seviyeye düşüyor
enerji ne kadar düşükse o kadar kararlı
oluyor işte Bak iki tane hidrojen atomu
biri bir tane elektron getiriyor diğeri
de bir tane elektron getiriyor Bu ne
yapıyor bili biliyor musun Bak ortak
kullanılan elektronların özelliği şudur
Bunun için de sayabilirsin bak ne oldu
kendim kendini helyuma benzetti diğeri
için de sayabilirsin Bak bu da kendini
helyuma benzetti İkisi de kararlı oldu
işte bu itme çekme kuvvetlerinin dengeli
olduğu anda potansiyel enerji minimum
oluyor ve burada da kararlı hale geliyor
Eğer ben bunları bu atomları
birbirlerine daha çok yaklaştırır ve bu
durumda ne olacak elektronlar da bu
protonlar da çekirdekler de birbirlerini
daha çok itmek isteyecek bir arada
tutmak için daha fazla potansiyel enerji
gerekir e potansiyel en enerji artınca
yani enerji artınca kararlılık bozuluyor
ki onu da sana şurada göstereceğim
neredeydi dur Heh burada Bak burada
potansiyel Enerjileri sıf Ne oldu
yaklaşmaya başladı çekim Kuvvetleri
fazla işte potansiyel enerji az bir şey
işte azaldı diyeyim öyle söyleyeyim Daha
sonra öyle bir an geldi ki itme çekme
Kuvvetleri birbirini dengelediği
enerji arttığı için ne oluyor
kararsızlık oluyor burada hangilerinden
bahsedebiliriz şu durum ve şu durum da
kararsız ama buradaki durumda kararlı
olduğunu söyleyebiliriz Molekülün işte
bak ne oldu ortak kullanılmaya başlandı
ortak kullanıldığında elektronlar bunun
çevresinde de dolanıyor bunun çevresinde
de dolanıyor işte ortak kullandıklarında
İkisi de kararlıyım gibi oluyor yani
İkisi de helyuma benzemiş oluyor işte
kovalent bağı yapmasının temel sebebi bu
şöyle de bir şey söyleyebilirim mesela
oksijenden bahsedelim oksijen 2'ye 6
soygaza benzemek istiyorsa bak soygaza
benzemek istiyorsa ne yapmak ister 8'e
tamamlamak ister değil mi son katmanını
yani neye ihtiyacı var İki elektrona
ihtiyacı var Düşünsene Bak bir tane
oksijen burada duruyor bir tane oksijen
de burada duruyor Bu da mesela 2'ye 6
şöyle göstereyim bunun ikisini şöyle
göstereyim elektronlarını bunun ikisini
de 2'ye 6 Hani şunlar ikinci katmanlar
böyle gösterelim diyor ki ya keşke bana
biri iki elektron verse de kararlı olsam
öteki diyor ki keşke bana da iki tane
veren olsa da kararlı olsam o zaman ne
yapıyor biliyor musun diyor ki gel şöyle
bir şey yapalım diyor sen bana iki
taneyi getir ben sana iki taneyi
getireyim bunları ortak kullanalım diyor
ortak kullandıktan sonra toplam 4
elektron ortak kullanılıyor 4te
kullanmadıkları var 88'e tamamlamış
oluyoruz hocam Ne alaka diyeceksin bak
şöyle düşün burada çekirdeğim var
oksijenin birinci katmanı 2 2ci
katmanında Şöyle 1 2 3 4 5 6 tane var
diğer oksijeni yapayım o da olmadı dur
Heh şöyle diğer oksijeni yapalım
çekirdek 2 tane elektron birinci
katmanda 1 2 3 4 5 6 diyor ki gel bak
diyor sen bana Şuradan iki elektron
getir diyor şuradan şöyle ben de iki
elektronunu getireyim bunları ortak
kullanalım diyor bak şöyle yapıyorlar şu
şekilde şöyle yapıyorlar çekirdekleri
şurada duruyor çekirdekleri aynı yerde
şu elektronlar şurada duruyor bak ikişer
elektron getirdiklerinde toplam 1 2 3 4
elektronu ortak kullanıyorlar diğer
dördünü zaten Ortak kullanmıyor lardı bu
şekilde yani ortaklaşa kullandıkları
toplam 4 elektron her bir atomdan iki
tane geldi ve ortaklaşa kullanmadıkları
4 elektron şöyle düşün Bak şu şekilde
göstereyim şu oksijene bakarsan son
katmanında kaç oldu ortak kullanılanları
da sayarsan 8 oldu değil mi aynısını
şunun için yap Ne oldu bu da 8 oldu işte
ikisi de soygaza benzedi kararlı hale
gelmiş oldu ama 4 tane elektronu ortak
kullandı demin bir şey söylemiştim iki
tane elektronu ortak kullandıklarında
bir bağ dememiş miydim E o zaman burada
oksijen iki tane çift kullanıyor toplam
4 elektronu ortak kullandığı için iki
bağ yapmış oluyor yani her iki elektron
bir bağ anlamına geliyor diğerlerini Bak
şurada ortak kullanmadı değil mi onlar
bu şekilde burada duruyor Dostum şimdi
H2 molekülünde demin söyledim ya o
bağlanma durumundan bahsettim işte H2
molekülünde çekirdekler arasındaki itme
Kuvvetleri ile çekirdek ve elektronlar
arasındaki çekme Kuvvetleri dengeli hale
geldiğinde kararlı hale gelmiş oluyorlar
e Burada da işte Yani bir çift elektron
ne yapmış oluyor bağı oluşturmuş oluyor
bir elektron çifti yani her kovalent bağ
bir elektron çifti iç ifadesini
kullanıyoruz şunu da şöyle hemen şeye
alalım kutucuğa alalım önemli bir
bilgidir Çünkü ve şöyle bir şey vardır
aralarında kovalent bağ olan iki atomun
çekirdekleri arasındaki mesafeye Biz bağ
uzunluğu diyoruz Bunlar ne kadar
birbirine yaklaşırsa o bağın enerjisi de
o kadar artıyor bağ uzunluğu işte
atomdan atoma değişmekte Her atomun K
farklı olmakta mesela aynı atom türü
arasında diyelim tek bağ varsa şöyle bir
boyda diyelim iki bağ varsa kısalıyor 3
bağ varsa daha da kısalıyor bunu ek
bilgi olarak ek sıradan söylemiş olayım
ve şöyledir kovalent bağlı moleküllerde
şöyle bir şeyden bahsediyoruz biz aynı
ametal atomları da olabilir mesela H2 N2
başka O2 F2 gibi veya farklı ametal
atomları arasında da olabilir CO2 H2O
başka nh3 gibi bunlara biz işte Ne
diyoruz molekül diyoruz yani kovalent
bağlı bileşikler molekül yapılıdır
potansiyel enerji değişim sürecini
söylemiştim demiştik ki işte şurada
sıfırdı Ne oldu yaklaşmaya başladılar
sonra iyice yaklaştılar itme ve çekme
Kuvvetleri dengelendiği de ne hale
gelmiş oldu kararlı hale gelmiş oldu
Eğer daha da fazla yaklaştırır San
kararsız olacaktır ifadesini kullandım
Burada da bunları açıklıyorum Dostum
şimdi şundan bahsedelim polar kovalent
bağ apolar kovalent bağ Allah Allah Bu
ne demek aslında o kadar basit bir şey
var ki şimdi burada detaylı bir şekilde
anlatacağım ama inanılmaz pratik bir
yöntemi var o da şudur aynı ametal
atomları arasında apolar kovalent bağ
farklı Amet atomları arasında polar
kovalent bağ bulunur şöyle bir şeydir bu
polar apolar ne demek kutuplu kutupsuz
anlamındadır polar kutuplu bağ yani
orada artı eksi kutuplaşması vardır
apolar Demek ki o da kutupsuz zıt anlamı
ifade etmekte ya hani organik anorganik
gibi böyle düşünebilirsin Metal ametal
işte burada da polar kutuplu apolar
kutupsuz Peki bu ne demek işte aynı
ametal atomları arasında ne olacak
elektron ortak kullanılıyor değil mi
Şöyle göstereyim bak hidro hidrojenle
hidrojen ortak kullanılan elektron iki
tane ya ortada duruyor aha şöyle duruyor
diyor ki bu hidrojen elektronegatifliği
var E diğer hidrojenin de
elektronegatifliği var diyor ki ben bu
elektronları benim çevremde dolansın
diye istiyorum diyor bende dolansın
ortak Ama benden daha ortak olsun benim
çevremde dolansın öteki diyor ki olur mu
öyle şey benim çevremde dolansın diyor
eşit güçte çekiyorlar eş eşit güçte
çektiği için de ne oluyor bu elektronlar
dengeli bir şekilde kalıyor elektron
eksi yüklü değil mi şimdi normalde bak
şöyle düşün hidrojen neydi şuydu değil
mi hidrojen Bu haliyle nötür değil mi
eğer Bak eğer bu hidrojen gelip de
proton sayısı 1 ken elektron sadece Onun
çevresinde dolansaydı ne gibi olurdu
elektron eksi yüklü olduğu için eksi
yüklü gibi olurdu değil mi He işte bak
elektronu kim kendine çekiyorsa o eksi
yüklü olacak diğeri ne olacaktır O zaman
o elektronu kaybetmiş gibi olacak ki
ortak kullanıyordu onların içerisinde
bir tanesi de onun e ne oluyor Onu
kaybetmiş oldu o zaman da diğeri artı
gibi oluyor ama burada ikisi de aynı
güçte çektiği için hangi tarafa eksi
diyebilirsin hangi tarafa artı di
diyebilirsin hiçbir tarafa diyemezsin
işte burada kutuplaşma yok Bundan dolayı
da apolar kovalent bağ diyoruz şuna aynı
ametal atomları arasında örnek vereyim
azotla azot arasında üç bağ vardır ki
birazdan detayl acağı bunu işte
buradakiler nedir apolar kovalent bağdır
veya başka bir örnek ne olsun flor olsun
florla flor arasındaki bağ apolar
kovalent bağdır Çünkü ortak kullanılan
elektronları İkisi de eşit güçte çekiyor
Tamam mı Şimdi burada örneklendir ve
şöyle bir şey vardır apoler kovalent
bağlarda ki elektronegatiflik farkından
bahsederiz unutmaman gereken bir bilgi
daha yazacağım şuraya
elektronegatiflik farkı arttıkça bağın
polarlığı artar o zaman apolar kovalent
bağda elektronegatiflik farkı nedir ıdır
değil mi Çünkü ikisinin de
elektronegatifliği aynı İki atomun da
elektronegatifliği aynıysa fark ne
oluyor 0 oluyor Bundan dolayı şöyle bir
şey söylüyoruz apolar kovalent Bağlar
için % 10000 kovalent bağ ismini
veriyoruz ama polarlar için % 10000
kovalent ba demiyoruz az da olsa bir
iyonik karakteri oluyor Onların şimdi
gel Heh şuraya geldik hidrojenden
bahsedelim hidrojende diyor ki ya ben
helyuma benzemek istiyorum hidrojen
helyuma benzemek istiyor Diyor ki bana
bir elektron öbürü diyor ki ya Bana da
bir elektron gel o zaman ortak
kullanalım diyorlar İkisi de kararlı
hale geldi bir atomun helyuma
benzemesine dublet yani elektron
dizilimini helyuma benzetmesine dublet
diyoruz diğer soygazlara ki yani son
katmanı 8 olması durumundan bahsediyoruz
benzemesine oktet kuralı denilmektedir E
o zaman burada hidrojen atomları ne
olacaktır dublet olacaktır değil mi
Çünkü helyuma benzedi değil mi Her ikisi
de helyuma benzediği için dublet diyoruz
buna burada ortak kullandıkları için
Şunlara bağlayıcı elektron çifti diyoruz
Yani iki hidrojen atomu birer
elektronlarını ortak kullandığı için
şuna Biz bağlayıcı elektron çifti ismini
veriyoruz dostum bağlayıcı elektron
çifti Peki hidrojenin boşta başka
elektronu kaldı mı yok işte o da
bağlayıcı olmayan elektron çifti ya da
ortaklaşması bu yok dostum yani
bağlayıcı olmayan valance elektronu yani
değerlik elektronu bulunmamakta Ama
mesela bak F2 molekülüne baktığımızda F2
molekülünde son katmanında 7 elektron
var f = nedir 2'ye 7 şöyleydi ya soygaza
benzemek istiyor bir tane elektronu olsa
mis gibi soygaza benzeyecek diyor ki ya
benim bir elektrona ihtiyacım var diyor
ki Tamam Benim de Bir taneye ihtiyacım
var Gel bunları ortak kullanalım
diyorlar bak aha ortak kullanılan bir
çift elektron var Yani şöyle florla flor
arasında şöyle bir çifti ortak
kullandılar böyle duruyor ama bak
değerlik elektronlarına dikkat eder
misin florun hala 1 2 3 çifti daha var
yani Şunlara Ortak kullanılmadı yani bağ
yapmadı aynı şey diğerinde de söz konusu
bu şekilde gösterebilirim işte şuna şu
ortak kullandıklarına bağlayıcı elektron
çifti ismini veriyoruz şunlara bak bak
Şunlara bağ oluşumuna katılmadı değil mi
6 tane burada var 1 2 3 6 da burada var
12 tane bağlayıcı olmayan elektronu
bulunmakta çift deseydi 6 çift olacaktı
tamam mı Mesela burada da bağlayıcı
elektron sayısı deseydik ne olacaktı 2
olacaktı dostum ve sadece bir çifti
ortak kullandıkları için de ne oluyor
burada bir tane apolar kovalent bağdan
bahsediyoruz aynı durumu Başka nerede
söyleyebiliriz hemen Bakalım bakalım
bakalım aha oksijenden bahsedelim şimdi
oksijenin değerlik elektron sayısı 6 2
elektronu olsa mis gibi kararlı hale
gelecek diyor ki ya ben nereden
bulacağım iki elektronu diğer oksijen
diyor ki gel Ben de vereyim diyor ikişer
tane elektronu ortak kullandığımızda
toplam 4 tane elektronu ortak kullanmış
oluyoruz şöyle sığdırmak için şöyle
yapayım 4 elektronu ortak kullanalım
diyor oksijenler Ee diğer iki tanesini
hala kullanmadı değil mi pardon diğer
dör tanesini kullanmadı şöyleydi Çünkü
oksijen 2ye 6'yı ya da 1 S2 2 S2 2p 4'tü
e 2 elektrona ihtiyacı vardı ikisini
ortak kullandığında dördünü hala
kullanmamış oldu birazdan şekille de
göstereceğim şurada işte bak her bir
çift bir bağ ettiğine göre oksijenle
oksijen arasında ne olacaktır 2 bağ
olacaktır şunlar da Bağ oluşumuna
katılmayan vardı yani burada Toplam 2 4
6 8 tane elektron bağlayıcı olmayan ya
da 4 çift diye de söyleyebilirsin İki
tane de Gördüğün gibi ne var bağlayıcı
elektron çifti var yani ne oldu iki bağ
var aynı ametal atomları olduğu için de
ne diyoruz buna apolar kovalent Bah
diyoruz Aha görüntü burada işte ne
yapıyor bir elektronu şöyle aldı diyelim
bir elektronu da şöyle aldı toplam 4
elektronu ortak kullandı diğerleri
kullanılmadı dikkat et bak ne oldu
oksijen Şu haliyle kendini 8'e tamamladı
oktet oldu değil mi aynı durum şunun
için de geçerli Bak bu da 8E tamamladı
Bu da oktete ulaşmış oldu toplam iki
tane bağ yapmış oldu Şurada ne diyoruz o
zaman iki tane apolar kovalent bağ
diyoruz kovalent pa aynı durum Bir de
şöyle n2den bahsederek açıklayalım bunu
mesela 1 S2 2 S2 2 P3 ya da 2'ye 5 diye
söyleyelim 8'e tamamlamak istiyorsa 3
elektrona ihtiyacı var Bu azot diyor ki
bana keşke diyor biri 3 tane elektron
verse öbür azot da diyor ki benim de
ihtiyacım var Gel o zaman ortak
kullanalım diyor şöyle yapıyorlar işte
şunu da şöyle alalım mesela toplam üçer
tane elektronu ortak kullandıklarında o
zaman azotla azot arasında her bir çift
bir bağ demek olduğu için 6 Ne oldu
burada 6 elektron var yani 3 çift var ü
bağ yaptı ama bak hala kullanılmayan iki
elektron var Onları da şöyle
gösteriyorum Demek ki bu molekülde ne
olacaktır toplam 4 tane bağlayıcı
olmayan elektron ama 6 tane de bağlayıcı
elektronu olacaktır ya da 3 çift
bağlayıcı elektron iki çift bağlayıcı
olmayan elektron diyoruz burada da tam
olarak söylediğimi Açıklıyor Dostum 3
tane bağ olduğuna göre ve aynı ametal
atomlar arasında olduğu için apolar
kovalent bağ sayısı ne olacaktır burada
3 tane olacaktır Bir de polar kovalent
bağ var ki polar kovalent bağ da şudur
mesela hidrojenle flor florun
elektronegatifliği daha büyüktür florun
elektronegatifliği büyük olduğu için
ortak kullanılan elektronlar flor
tarafından daha çok çekilmekte Yani
şöyle düşün kar ortaklığı var Burada kar
ortaklığında diyelim Bu getirdi bir kaç
1 milyon dolar koydu ama bu getirdi 7
milyon dolar koydu değil mi Örnek
veriyorum Şu anda E o zaman diyor ki
arkadaş ben 7 milyon dolar koydum Tamam
orta az ama benim diyor payım daha fazla
elektronegatifliği daha büyük
elektronegatifliği büyük olduğu için o
ortak kullandıkları elektronlar kimin
çevresinde daha çok dolanıyor florun
çevresinde dolanıyor O yüzden bak ne
oldu hidrojen ortak kullanılan elektron
ondan Uzakta olduğu için sanki şey
elektronu kaybetmiş gibi oluyor o zaman
bu taraf elektron sayısı azaldığı için
kısmen artı oluyor kısmen demek şu ya o
elektron Sürekli orada değil arada bunun
çevresinde de dolanıyor ama az dolanıyor
ya genel olarak artı gibi duruyor e
diğerinde ise elektron hep Onun
çevresinde dolandığı için çoğunlukla
dolandığı için orada da elektron
fazlalığından dolayı ne oluyor eksi
yüklü oluyor işte kısmen artı kısmen
eksi kutuplaşma oldu gördün mü işte
ortak kullanılan elektronlar
elektronegatiflikleri farklı olduğunda
ve elektronegatiflik ne demekti bağ
elektronlarına sahip çıkma gücü işte bağ
elektronlarına biri daha fazla sahip
çıktığı için o taraf eksi yüklü oluyor
Diğer taraf artı yüklü oluyor kutuplaşma
oldu işte Farklı ametal atomlar arasında
polar kovalent bağ oluşmakta diyoruz
işte burada da tam olarak benim
söylediklerimi Açıklıyor dostum bunlara
da bakmanı istiyorum Gel şimdi bazı
moleküllerden bahsedelim ama öncesinde
şunu söyleyeyim polar kovalent bağlarda
kutupluluk olduğu için elektronegatiflik
farkı 0 değil 0 olduğunda neydi apolar
kovalent bağı ı bu fark arttıkça
elektronegatiflik farkı arttıkça ne
oluyordu polarlık artıyordu ama iyonik
karaktere doğru gitmeye başlıyorsun Yani
polar moleküller % 10000 kovalent bağlı
değildir çok az da olsa iyonik karakteri
mevcuttur diyoruz burada Mesela H ve H2
o nh3 CO2 ve ch4 bahsedeceğim bunları
istersen detaylı bir şekilde bakalım
Diyor ki hidrojen Tamam geldik hidrojeni
yazdık diyor ki keşke benim bir tane
elektron olsa da soygaza benzesem
helyuma benzemeye çalışıyor ya bak bu
helyuma benzemeye çalışıyor şöyle diğeri
ney flor bak flor 9 2'ye 7 diyor ki
keşke diyor bir tane elektron olsa da B
de şeye benzesem neona benzesem o zaman
diyor ki gel ortak kullanalım diyor bak
şöyle ortak kullanıyorlar ORT
kullandıklarında dikkat et bu ne yaptı
bak helyuma benzedi Bak bu ne yaptı
neona benzedi yani İkisi de soygaza
benzedi mi E benzedi e burada
baktığımızda flor için ne söyleyebiliriz
oktet kuralına uymuştur son katmanı 8'e
tamamladı e burada hidrojen için ne
söyleyebiliriz dublet kuralına uymuştur
O da helyuma benzediği için Dostum şimdi
burada florun elektronegatifliği yazalım
elektr
negatiflik 7A grubu 1A grubuna göre daha
fazlaydı yani florun elektronegatifliği
hidrojenden büyüktür o zaman bak
hidrojenle flor arasında bir elektron
çifti ortak kullanıldığı için ne olacak
elektronlar flor tarafından daha çok
çekilecek Bundan dolayı da flor tarafı
kısmen negatif olacak hidrojen tarafı
kısmen pozitif olacak kaç çift elektron
kullanıldı bir tane şöyle HP bu bağ
nedir dersek polar kovalent bağ şeklinde
söyleyebiliriz dostum H2O molekülünden
bahsedelim bak hidrojen 1 çok güzel
helyuma benzemek istiyor oksijen 8 2'ye
6 E bu da zaten soygaz olarak neona
benzemek istiyor Yani bunun 2 elektrona
ihtiyacı var bunun bir elektrona
ihtiyacı var diyor ki abi oksijen abi
şöyle yapalım mı diyor ben şöyle
duruyorum diyor bak Tamam oksijen abi
Sen şöyle duruyorsun çok güzel diyor
şurada diyor iki elektrona ihtiyacım var
Ben diyor geleyim diyor hidrojenin bir
tanesi şöyle yapıyor geleyim diyor
şuraya bağlanayım diyor şöyle yapayım
diyor hidrojen Bir tanesi buraya geldi
Diğer hidrojen de geldi abi ben de böyle
geleyim diyor şöyle iki tane hidrojen
bağlanıyor Çünkü bir tane hidrojenin bir
tane elektrona ihtiyacı var E oksijenin
iki tane ihtiyacı olduğu için ne oluyor
Bir oksijene iki tane hidrojen bağlanmış
oluyor ki işte görüntü tam olarak böyle
oluyor diyor ki gel Biz böyle ortak
kullanalım Öteki de diyor ki gel Biz
böyle ortak kullanalım bak kullandıkları
elektronlar bu şekilde gösteriliyor
Böylelikle bak oksijen burada her bir
çift şunlar bir bağ olduğu için bu
şekilde bir yapı meydana geliyor bak
Şunlara kullanılmayan elektronlar burada
ne söyleyebiliriz o zaman 1 ik çift
bağlayıcı olmayan elektron var 1 ik çift
de ba bağlayıcı elektron var diyebiliriz
ve buradaki işte hidrojen oksijen farklı
ametal atomu değil mi Evet o zaman bu
bağ nedir polar kovalent bağdır
diyebiliriz şöyle kovalent Heh yazamadık
E şimdi burada oksijenin
elektronegatifliği hidrojenden büyük o
zaman ortak kullanılan elektronlar kime
daha yakın olacak dostum Tabii ki
oksijene daha yakın olacak yani H2O
Şuraya bir daha çizmiş çok güzel aşağıya
çizmiş E elektronlar ne yapacak ortak
kullanılan elektronlar oksijene daha
yakın olduğu için oksijen tarafı negatif
olacak hidrojen tarafı da pozitif olacak
yani Neymiş o zaman bir bağda
elektronegatifliği büyük olan eksi yüklü
oluyormuş elektronegatifliği küçük
olansa artı yüklü oluyormuş CO2 molekülü
çok önemli bir moleküldür bak karbon 6
2'ye 4 keşke diyor Benim 4 tane elektron
olsa oksijen de diyor ki 2'ye 6 Benim de
diyor Keşke 2 elektron olsa o zaman
diyor ki karbon abi diyor gel şöyle
yapalım diyor bir oksijenle diyor şöyle
iki elektronu ortak kullanayım diğer
oksijenle de diğer iki elektronu ortak
kullan ım aha böyle bu hale geleyim
diyor o zaman karbon Ortada iki bağ diye
bir oksijenle yaptı iki bağ da diğer
oksijenle yaptı Çünkü 4 tane elektron
ortak kullanılıyor Gördüğün gibi E o
zaman Buraya bakarsak toplamda 1 2 3 4
tane bağ co O arasına bak Farklı ametal
atomlar arasında o zaman ne diyoruz
burada polar kovalent bağı diyoruz
İlginç olan bir şey daha söyleyelim mi O
da şu Karbonun değerlik elektronu
kalmadı bak hepsini kullandı Ama hocam
burada var İki tane bak şunlar var Onlar
alt katman değerlik katmanı son
katmandır görüyor musun Karbonun ikinci
katmanındaki tüm elektronlar bağa
katıldı O yüzden karbonda boşta valens
elektronu ya da değerlik elektronu
kalmadı ama oksijenin görüyor musun son
katmanında şu şekilde kaldı yani bu
molekülde bağa katılmayan yani bağ
yapmayan şöyle yazabiliriz bağlayıcı
elektron çifti bağlayıcı olmayan
elektron çifti 4 tanedir 1 2 3 4
oksijenden dolayı karbon da yok ama 1 2
3 4 de bağ var Gördüğün gibi 4 de
bağlayıcı elektron çifti yani dört bağ
vardır diyebiliriz ve CO2 molekülünde
şöyle bir şey vardır yazalım
elektronegatiflik şimdi karbon 4A grubu
e oksijen 6a grubu E ne oluyor 6a
grubunun elektronegatifliği daha
büyüktür oksijen karbondan daha büyük o
zaman ortak kullanılan elektronlar
oksijenl yakın olduğu için oksijenler
eksi yüklü olacaktır e haliyle Karbon ne
olacaktır artı yüklü olacaktır bak
kutuplaşma oldu amonyak molekülüne
geldiğimizde ise amonyakta işte hidrojen
bir tane elek elektrona ihtiyaç duyuyor
E azota 2'ye 5 şöyle 2'ye 5te 3
elektrona ihtiyaç duyuyor diyor ki gel
bak biz bunu şöyle ortak kullanalım
seninle şunu ortak kullanalım senle de
şunu ortak kullanalım Böylelikle 3 bağ
yapıyor nh3 yapısı aşağı yukarı şöyle
bir görüntü oluyor kullanılmayan iki
elektronu var azotun Onları da şöyle
belirtebilirim dostum Aha bak Görüyor
musun 1 2 3 tane bağlayıcı elektron
çifti var Buna Biz ne diyoruz işte
bağlayıcı elektron çiftleri kaç tane 3
tane ve farklı ametal atom değil mi
azotla hidrojen arasında o zaman ne
söyleyebiliriz burada polar kovalent bağ
sayısı 3 tanedir yorumunu yaparız
bağlayıcı olmayan elektron çifti de
neymiş Burada iki taney demiş elektron
çifti diyor bir taney demiş elektron
sayısı deseydi iki taneydi şimdi sana
bir tane örnek yazacağım Bak şöyle
karbon yazdım Hatta şöyle çift bağ
yaptım şuraya hidrojen yazdım hidrojen
yazdım hidrojen yazdım ve hidrojen
yazdım diyorum ki burada kaç tane polar
kovalent ba var Kaç tane apolar kovalent
bağ var Görüyor musun bak karbon
hidrojen farklı ametal atomu karbon
hidrojen karbon hidrojen ve karbon
hidrojen O zaman burada 4 tane polar
kovalent bağ vardır kovalent bağ şöyle
yazdık çok güzel e şurada görüyor musun
aynı ametal atom var nerede şurada
karbonla karbon 1 2 tane bağ var O zaman
burada iki tane apolar kovalent bağ
vardır diyebiliriz Şimdi bir de kovalent
bağın özelliklerinden bahsedelim sonra
da örnek çözelim bitirelim biraz cık
uzattım Çünkü burada diyor ki bak
kovalent moleküllerin özellikleri
moleküllerden oluşmaktadır yani burada
birim hücre yoktur kovalent bağlı
bileşiklerde bağımsız birimler yani
moleküller mevcuttur moleküller arasında
çoğunlukla zayıf etkileşimler vardır ki
ilerleyen kısımda söyleyeceğiz bunları
dipol dipol Ondan sonra ne vardı London
kuvvetleri vardı Hidrojen bağı vardı
onları daha sonra detayl acağı oda
koşullarında katı halde olanı vardır ki
şeker örnek verebiliriz iyotu örnek
verebiliriz sıvı halde olanı vardır ki
suy örnek verebiliriz gaz olanı vardır
ki mesela karbondioksit hidrojen oksijen
Bunlara örnek verebiliriz katı ve sıvı
halde Elektrik akımını iletmezler ama
bazılarının sulu çözeltisi hcl nh3 gibi
asit ve baz özelliği gösterenler suda
iyonlaşabilen
iyon yani Elektrik akımını iletenler
mevcuttur şimdi bakalım örneklerimiz ne
diyor Aşağıda verilen bilgiler doğru ise
D yanlış ise y şeklinde yazınız diyor
İki atom arasında ortaklaşa kullanılan
elektron çifti bir bağ oluşturduğu için
bağlayıcı elektron çifti olarak
adlandırılır Evet doğrudur söylemiştik
Çünkü cs2 molekülünde 4 bağlayıcı
elektron vardır diyor şimdi bak karbon
neydi 1 S2 2 S2 2 P2 yani 2'ye 4'tü 4
tane son katmanında elektronu var Bak
şöyle gösteriyorum şu şekilde Bunlar
birinci katman 1 2 3 4 böyle duruyor Ne
varmış Bir de kükürt varmış kükürt S16
neydi 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 4'tü Yani
bu da 2 8 6'yı son katmanında şöyle 3ün
katmanını yazıyorum 6 tane elektronu var
şöyle 1 2 3 4 5 6 tane var bu alt
katmanlar zaten dolu onları yazmayacağım
Aynı şey Burada da var 1 2 3 4 5 6 bu
şekilde duruyor diğer katmanlar böyle
şimdi bak ne olacak karbon 4 tane
elektron istiyor ama kükürt 2 tane
elektron istiyor o zaman diyor ki gel
bak şunları Biz ortak kullanalım şöyle
Gel seninle de şunları ortak kullanalım
diyor ve şöyle bir yapı meydana ge
getirmiş oluyor karbon ortada toplamda
iki tane bu tarafla iki tane bu tarafla
ne oluşturdu bağ oluşturdu şu şekilde
bak kullanılmayan elektron çiftleri de
şunlar onları da şöyle göstereyim şu
şekilde aynısını bu tarafta da
gösterelim şöyle şu şekilde Ha o zaman 1
2 3 4 tane bağ yapabildiği için 4
bağlayıcı elektronu vardır diyor
bağlayıcı elektron çifti olması
gerekiyordu ha çift demiş mi demiş o
zaman Doğrudur diyor ki aynı tür ametal
atomları arasında oluşan iki atomlu
moleküller apolar kovalent Evet doğru N2
H2 O2 F2 gibi aynı ametal atomlar
arasında oluşan Bağlar neydi apolar
kovalent bağ olarak ifade ediliyordu
diyor ki polar kovalent bağlarda
elektronegatifliği büyük olan kısmi
pozitiftir Hayır elektronegatifliği
büyük olan elektronu kendine çekiyor
elektron eksi yüklü olduğu için
elektronegatifliği büyük olan negatif
yüklüdür O yüzden bu yanlıştır diyor ki
ch4 ve CO2 moleküllerinde bağ yapımına
katılan elektron sayıları farklıdır bak
CO2 nasıldı yukarıda göstermiştim şöyle
bir yapıdı ch4 ise bak hidrojen bir bağ
yapabiliyordu deminden beri gösteriyoruz
e karbona 4 bağ yapabiliyordu onu da
deminden beri gösteriyorum e burada o
zaman bak karbon 1 2 3 4 bağ yaptı
hidrojenle karbon arasında da toplamda 1
2 3 4 bağ var yani ch4 ve CO2
moleküllerinde bağ yapımına katılan
elektron sayısı toplamda İkisinde de 4
bağ olduğu için 4 çift yani eşittir O
yüzden Ne oldu farklıdır dediği için
yanlış oldu burada bu şekilde belirlemiş
olduk buradaki soruya bakalım Diyor ki
he elektron sayıları verilmiştir diyor
bu elementlerden oluşan aşağıdaki
moleküllerden hangisinin ortaklanmamış
yani bağa katılmayan elektron sayısı
yanlış verilmiştir diyor şimdi Bak
burada azotun 5 tane noktası var şöyle O
son katmanını şöyle göstereyim mi 1 2 3
4 5 diye göstereyim 3 tane bağ yapmak
istiyor azot e n2den bahsediyor diğer
azottan bahsedelim 1 2 3 4 5 şöyle 3
tane bağ yapacak azotla azot 3 tane bağ
yaptı bağ oluşumuna katılmayan Toplamda
4 tane elektron var bağ yapmayan
elektron sayısı 4 yani ortaklanmamış
elektron sayısı 4 ifadesi doğru oldu
şimdi ne var burada H2O var oksijen 6y
dı 1 2 3 4 5 6 diye yazdım şu şekilde
iki tane bağ yapmak istiyor ki soygaza
benzesin 8E tamamlamak istiyor
hidrojenler le bağlanıyor bak ne yaptı
hidrojen birini bağladı Diğerini de
bağladı son katmanına göre yazdım şunlar
da katılmadı değil mi böyle gözüküyor O
zaman bak şunlar bağ oluşumuna katılmadı
hidrojenle oksijen arasındaki görüntü bu
şunlar bağ şunlar da katılmadı Yani
şöyle ortaklanmamış elektron sayısı 4
oldu Böylelikle Doğrudur nh3 diyor şimdi
azot neydi 1 2 3 4 5 tane noktası vardı
Son katmanında hidrojen ne bağ yapacaktı
3 bağ yapacaktı çünkü yani şeyden nasıl
söyleyeyim sana soygazdan kaç eksikse o
şekilde bağ sayısını bulabilirsin Bak
tekrar pratik olarak yapalım neydi 2'ye
4'tü değil mi son katmanında 4 elektron
var 4 olsa ne yapar soygaza benzer Demek
ki bu 4 bağ yapmak istiyor azota bak 7
2'ye 5i 3 tane alsa soygaza benzeyecek o
zaman 3 bağ yapmak istiyor oksijen 8
2'ye 6'yı 2 tane alsa soygaza benzeyecek
Demek ki 2 bağ yapmak istiyor başka bir
örnek vereyim mesela mesela Kimi
verebilirim hidrojen hidrojen bir
helyuma benzemek için bir tane ihtiyacı
var bir bağ yapıyor o zaman bak Ne oldu
şunlar şöyle bağ oluşturdu Eyvallah
şöyle bağ oluşturdu şunlar da katılmadı
Gördüğün gibi bir çift var burada ama
elektron sayısı diyor çifti demiyor 2
demesi gerekiyordu ona Geleceğim şimdi
karbondioksit var bak karbon 4 bağ
yapmak istiyor oksijen 2 bağ yapmak
istiyor al bu şekilde yaptık e oksijenin
toplamda kaç tane elektronu vardı son
katmanında 6 1 2 şu bağda kullanılanlar
2 şunları yazdık aynı şekilde kaç etti
Burası 2 ha ortak kullanılanları Tamam
6'yı tamamladık burada aynı durum şurada
söz konusu çizemedim Ha şöyle şöyle
şunlar kullandıkları Bunlar da
kullanmadıkları 1 2 3 4 çift yani 8
elektronu kullanmıyor Bu da tamam O2
molekülüne bakalım oksijen 2 bağ
yapacaktı diğer oksijenle yaptı şunlar
da katılmadı son katmanındaki diğer
elektronlar e Toplamda 2 4 6 8 tanesi
katılmadı Doğrudur Ha biz Neyi arıyorduk
yanlışı arıyorduk cevabımız C
seçeneğidir şimdi sana bir ufak şey
yapacağım böyle pratik bir şey den
bahsedeceğim şöyle bir tane atom var
tamam mı Şöyle yaptı diyelim şöyle yaptı
şu şekilde çizdi dedi ki x atomunun Grup
numarası nedir şimdi bak şurada bir
bağda iki elektron yok muydu her bağ iki
elektronda elektronun birisi hidrojene
aitse diğeri neye aittir x'e aittir aynı
durum şurada söz konusu aynı durum
şurada söz konusu o zaman bak x'te son
katmandaki elektronlar Ne oldu 1 2
şurada gözükenler söyleyerek ifade
ediyorum 1 2 3 4 5 tane oldu he Bunlar
hidrojen iniler Çünkü Ne oldu o zaman 5A
grubu elementi diyebilirsin veya başka
bir örnek vereyim y dedim Mesela şöyle
yaptım dur He şöyle yaptım bunu da
mesela Z dedim y z işte Şunlara da şöyle
belirttim Mesela dedi ki y ve Z'nin
gruplarını Söyle şimdi bak şu
elektronlardan birer tanesi her bağdaki
birer elektron ne olacaktır bu bu atoma
ait olacaktır Burası 4 4A grubuyum Muş e
diğerine Bak şöyle 1 2 3 4 5 6 Bu da 6a
grubu böyle yapabilirsin Dostum şimdi
buradaki soruya bakalım Diyor ki element
atomları arasında meydana gelen
şunlardan bahsediyor bazı şeyler vermiş
bunların molekül içi Bağları ile ilgili
yorum yap demiş Şimdi x 13 1 S2 2 S2 2p
6 3 S2 3 P1 3A grubu elementi yani x
metaldir çok güzel Y'ye bakalım 7 diyor
y7 1 S2 2 S2 2p 3 5A grubu elementi y de
ametal yazalım ametal e burada bak Y2
diyor görüyor musun İlkinde Y2 aynı
ametal atomlar arasında ne oluyordu
apolar kovalent bağ oluşuyordu bunu
işaretledikten ametal Şimdi x ile z x
metal Z ametal Metal ametal arasında
iyonik bağlı bileşik oluş onu da
yapıştırdık şuraya baktık Z ametal y de
ametal ametal ametal arasında kovalent
bağ oluşuyor farklı ametal atomlar
arasında ne oluyordu polar kovalent bağ
oluşuyordu O yüzden cevabım B
seçeneğidir son olarak şuna bakalım X2
molekülünün elektron şeması verilmiştir
diyor şimdi bak Dikkat et şunlar 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 bunlar bir atoma ait ortak
kullanılanlardan bir tanesi bir atoma
ait diğeri de ötekine 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
ikisinin de değerlik elektron sayısı
7'dir O yüzden X'in değerlik elektron
sayısı 7'dir ifadesi Doğrudur Burada
dikkat et Şimdi bak şu da kendini 8'e
tamamladı şu da kendini 8'e tamamladı
değil mi ortak kullanılanları da sayarak
söylüyorduk ya biz buna Ne diyorduk
oktete ulaşmak diyorduk diyor ki
moleküldeki atomlar oktet kuralına Uyar
Doğrudur diyor ki X2 molekülünde diyor
ki atomlar arasında tekli kovalent bağ
vardır Şurayı silerek gösteriyorum ortak
kullandıkları elektron sadece bir çift
değil mi Şöyle bir çift elektronu ortak
kull kullanıyorsa bir bağ yapıyordur
Doğrudur Toplamda 4 çifti şöyle diyeyim
Eee 4 elektron ortak kullansaydı E ne
olacaktı o zaman 2 bağ yapmış olacak Her
iki elektron bir bağ ya 6 elektronu
ortak kullansaydı 3 bağ yapacaktı
diyecektik diyor ki x elementi bir
halojenden 7A grubu elementidir
halojenden bahsediyoruz ametal ametal
arasında İyonik bağ değil kovalent bağ
vardır kovalent bağ da elektron
ortaklaşması ile oluşur O yüzden bu
ifade yanlıştır Cevap e seçeneğidir Evet
güzel insan ne yapmış olduk kovalent
Bağları şöyle hızlı bir şekilde tekrar
etmiş olduk detaylarına girmeye çalıştım
Bak her detaya girmeye çalıştım daha
sonraki dersimde Levis yapısından
bahsedeceğim Levis yapısına gelmeden
önce Aslında kısmen sana Levis yapısını
da anlatmış oldum Böyle çaktırmadan
anlatmış oldum Bir sonraki derste onu
daha iyi anlayacaksın sonraki dersimizde
Levis yapısından bahsedeceğim önemli bir
kısımdır Bir önceki dersi anlamak için
de kullanacaksın bunu şimdi bunu tekrar
etmen çok önemli yani Bu dersi tekrar
etmen çok önemli ne diyoruz Tekrar
hatırlatalım o zaman aynı ametal atomlar
arasında apolar kovalent bağ var Farklı
ametal atomlar arasında polar kovalent
bağ vardır diyoruz Önemli bir bilgiyi
her bir çift ortak kullanılan elektron
bir bağ etmektedir yani Bir çifti ortak
kullanıyorsa bir bağ iki çift ortak
kullanıyorsa Yani toplam 4 elektron
ortak kullanıyorsa 2 ba 6 elektron Ortak
kullanıyorsa yani 3 çift ortak kullanım
varsa Ne diyorduk üç bağ yapıyor
diyorduk işte ortak kullanılan
elektronlara bağlayıcı elektron çifti
ifadesini kullanıyoruz değerlik
elektronu olup da Bağ yapmayan
elektronlara Ne diyorduk bağlayıcı
olmayan elektronlar ya da ortaklanmamış
elektronlar şeklinde ifade ediyorduk
dostum Hadi O Zaman dinlenme vakti şu
kanala abone olmazsan Bak gerçekten
kızacağım kanala abone ol Daha bu
şekilde çok içerikler üreteceğim sana bu
müfredatı yeni müfredatı Bak daha şeye
kadar 12'ye kadar bu şekilde anlatacağım
daha sınava gireceğiz Biz Biz ÖSYM'nin
yaptığı sınavlara gireceğiz hepsine seni
hazırlayacağım elimizden geldiğince
kitaplar da çıkaracağız zedu Yayınları
olarak Artık yeni yeni kitaplar
göreceksiniz çok güzel şeyler
göreceksiniz O yüzden takipte kalmayı
unutmayın iki fosfor bir asit kimya Bu
kadar basit bir sonraki derste görüşmek
üzere hoşça kal